so far most of what we've been focused
on has been europe and some of y'all
have argued that hey why is this called
world war one it should be called europe
war one but in reality especially
because the major european powers had
these empires throughout the globe it
really was a world war the the most
significant fronts were the western
front and the eastern front but we have
many many many other fronts many other
campaigns and a lot of these helped
shape the modern world especially the
world of the 20th century you had fronts
you had fronts in campaigns in africa
between the various college the various
colonies that the empires had in africa
you had a front here in the caucuses
between the ottoman empire and and
russia you had japan involved japan in
world war one was on the side of the
allies it wasn't one of the major actors
in world war one but it helped provide
naval support it helped against some of
germany's colonies in the pacific and in
china but i want to what i really want
to focus on in this video is in some
ways one of the most interesting
campaigns or i guess several campaigns
of world war one because it really
helped shape the modern middle east and
a lot of
the way countries are shaped now and a
lot of the conflicts that we now see in
the middle east to some degree can be
tied to what happened leading up to
world war one and what happened after
world war one so just as a little bit of
context this entire region right over
here what we consider to be the middle
east now especially arabia was nominally
under ottoman control now the ottoman
empire had been losing power for
centuries leading up to the 20th century
especially if you look at the arabian
peninsula it was it wasn't direct
ottoman control it was very hard to
control the various arab tribes there
egypt by this point as we enter into
world war one in the late 1800s the
british occupied start began to occupy
egypt essentially took control of egypt
as we enter into world war 1 egypt is
officially a protectorate of the british
empire so this is egypt is for all
purposes it is it is british and egypt
is a huge strategic interest at this
point in time in fact it continues to be
a huge strategic interest because it has
the suez canal the suez canal is right
over here it can it connects
it's a man
man-made canal made in 1869 by the
french and it connects the mediterranean
sea with the red sea and to see its
importance you just have to look at the
map at a more global scale it's the
fastest way to get from europe by ship
into the red sea
and into the arabian sea
and to india which was a significant
part of the british empire there or to
go further east go into the indian ocean
and go to places further so it was a
huge huge huge strategic interest and so
that lays the groundwork for essentially
the various campaigns oftentimes they'd
be collectively called the middle east
campaigns or they're separated sometimes
as the sinai and palestine campaign and
the mesopotamia campaign mesopotamia
that's in modern day iraq the sinai
peninsula that's part of modern day
egypt
palestine in 1914 that's now been part
it's what what is what was then
considered palestine is now part of
israel part of the west bank part of the
gaza strip
part lebanon and as we'll see all of
these countries that we now recognize as
different countries lebanon
jordan
the
syria that these these were all kind of
carved and shaped by what happened at
the or during world war one and at the
end of world war one so as we get to the
beginning right at the right at the
outset in 1914 the british land the
british land right over here at at i
guess you could kind of kind of the
southern end of of mesopotamia and over
the course of the war they just keep
driving northward along the tigris river
so they keep they keep driving northward
and northward and northward by the end
of the war they've essentially captured
what you would consider kind of most of
modern day iraq and for the most part
it was it was a very successful campaign
for the british although they did have
some significant setbacks in particular
in particular at the end of 1915
you had a you have the british who are
who are held up it at a in in cout and
they were essentially sieged by the
ottoman empire 140 days siege
after 147 days
they had to surrender they were starving
in there they couldn't get supplies they
were dying of sickness this is actually
a picture of a of an indian soldier
after the siege of kut after they were
kind of taken by the ottomans after they
surrendered and even though the
mesopotamia camp the mesopotamian
campaign was successful for the british
it the the the siege of kut is kind of
recorded in british military history or
global military history is one of the
biggest humiliations for the british
army where you had that you had that
many troops who had to surrender they
were starving literally to death and one
thing i should point out i'm going to be
talking about the allies the british
troops but in the middle eastern
campaigns in the the sinai palestine
palestinian campaign
and in the mesopotamian campaign
indian troops which were part of the
british empire played a significant
factor especially in the mesopotamian
campaign and so did the australian and
new zealand group so when we talk about
british troops we're also talking about
all of the various nationalities that
were part of the british empire
so by 1918 they were able to capture
much of what is now modern day rock or
much of i guess you could say
mesopotamia and on the other side of uh
i guess you could call it you know on
the egyptian side of the campaign
the first few offenses were the first
few offensives were actually taken by
the ottomans they say hey look the
british hold the suez canal if we could
take back the suez canal that would be a
pretty crippling blow for the british
especially in their ability to get to
their the various ports of their empire
and so in 1915 you have the ottomans try
to make an offensive to try to capture
the suez canal it's repulsed it fails
they try again in 1916 that fails again
after that the british then take the
offensive and once again it's the
british but we're talking they have
egyptian troops they have arab troops
well egyptians are arabs they have
australian troops with them they have
indian troops with them
and they start to make an offensive and
that offensive essentially continues
through the course of world war one so
by
so by 1917 so 1915 they make the false
they they are able to defend the suez
canal 1916 they defend it again by 1917
they're making an offensive they're
making an offensive they're able to
after several after several tries
they're able to take gaza in 1917 then
they're able to take jerusalem which was
kind of a a
major source of prestige obviously
jerusalem has a thousands years history
of various armies trying to take
jerusalem but then they continue on and
by as as as they saw that the end of the
war was imminent especially as we get
into 1918 the british were and the
allies were essentially on a land grab
because they knew that as soon as an
armistice is called it's it's kind of
your last chance to grab more land and
then it goes to the bureaucrats to start
negotiating things so in 1918 the
british are essentially on a land grab
or especially the allies they take
damascus they they get all the way all
the way north to
to aleppo
and by the end of 1918
you essentially have the end of the war
you have the an armistice at the end of
october with the ottoman empire we know
that the austro-hungarians signed their
armistice in early november and so do
the germans in world war one is over now
there's a bunch of interesting things
here and you know i'm not i'm kind of
doing a very broad survey of these
campaigns one is the famous movie
lawrence of arabia it took place during
these campaigns this is a picture of t.e
lawrence who was a a well he was he was
he was many many many things but he was
this interesting character who tried who
who helped the the arabs rise up against
the ottomans against the turkish rule so
he was heavily involved in in helping to
coordinate the arab the arabs uprising
against the ottomans so in this case the
arabs were helping the allies
essentially push the ottomans push the
ottomans back now the most interesting
thing the outcome of this and we'll
probably talk into a lot more detail
about this in future videos is because
by the end of the war you have the
allies in control of all of this
territory in control let me do that in a
better color
in control
of
all of this territory right over here it
was really left to them to carve up the
modern middle east and it was agreed to
ahead of time that the that the french
would gain control of kind of you know
what is now syria and lebanon so this is
roughly lebanon's right over there syria
we're talking roughly
roughly this region including damascus
so roughly this region right over here
and it left the british in control of
what is now
what is now israel palestine
what is now israel palestine jordan
and
jordan and iraq and as we'll see as we
go into the 1920s this was all part of
the british mandate they carved it up
and and and a lot of their decisions
have led to a lot of what we now see as
a modern middle east and the french
essentially were in control up here in
lebanon and syria as part of the french
mandate